as you guys know last week I I covered
Logan Paul's beef with Dylan danis now
Logan and Dylan have a fight scheduled
on October 15th essentially a couple of
years ago Logan and his brother Jake had
a beef with Dylan and they ended up
sleeping with Dylan's ex-girlfriend now
Dylan did not
he did not forget this he this man was
like you know what I remember this
clearly so Dylan decides to tweet over a
hundred pictures of Logan's new fiance
with other men
now guys I just I've been on Twitter all
week I just kept wondering when will it
end every day I would pull up my Twitter
I'd be tweeting and I would just see
another picture of her with another
famous guy like from Bow Wow to
um Shark Boy you remember Sharkboy and
Lava Girl You Know shark boy she was
with then I think there was a picture of
her with maybe Shaq or something and
then um
you know Leonardo DiCaprio got in there
and I was just like guys this can't end
this can't get worse
Dylan until Dylan tweeted yesterday he
said if I dropped this picture it would
end the fight end his engagement and I
might even find myself in jail I'm
baffled like what what is this picture I
don't I I just can't imagine like what
is it a sex tape because at this point
there's already been like a hundred
dudes like I I genuinely think there's a
picture of a hundred guys so my question
is what is what is worse than this so
Andrew tweets back at him I was trying
very hard not to get involved in this
and I'm still trying to stay out of this
but I open my Twitter inbox and had a
message from Dylan and he's really not
lying I actually think this is good
because I think we're gonna have a
general conversation in society about
women with promiscuous past because okay
Logan's may have been public but we all
know that there are many men with wives
out there that have crazy past that
people don't know about and you know I I
was thinking about this the other day
and I was thinking about how men have so
much to lose in marriage like they have
everything to lose and these days
there's really not much to gain you know
we saw in the last video that there's a
50 divorce rate and if we assume half of
the men are unhappy in marriage you know
of them that stay married right and I
think that's a honestly
a generous number if I'm gonna be honest
um or they stay together for the kids or
whatever
it's really a 75 failure rate and I was
thinking about this and I'm like well if
you marry a hoe if a girl has over five
Partners she only has a 20 chance of a
happy marriage so knowing this
information I really think of men locked
down the marriage market like if
Leonardo DiCaprio the top guys got
together and said we are only marrying
virgins no other woman is qualified for
marriage I really think younger women
would adapt
um but the problem is we keep seeing
examples of women where it really works
out for you know um call her the chick
from caller daddy ended up getting
married or she's about to get married
you know we keep seeing men wife up hoes
you know even though that's the
exception it's not the rule you know the
media is going to spin it as if it is
the rule and so now we have Logan's uh
fiance who spent her 20s with every dude
in Hollywood and now is going to come
out at the finish line with a winner and
I think I think it just it really is
gonna red pill a lot of guys because she
did you know wait to have sex with him
and I think a lot of guys think that's
like a sign of Purity and you know
sometimes it's just a sign of a
predatory woman that's really just
learned the game
um not that I really have any real
answers for you guys I'm not I'm not the
queen of like pick up and telling you
all that stuff but my my I think of
things in like a general Society point
of view and I really think of men locked
down the marriage Mark and said you know
what
we're only doing virgins any everyone
else is just for fun and in five years
you know maybe the next round of like 21
22 year olds will wait and adapt I think
that's really because women don't really
care what the average guy wants
unfortunately I think you guys have seen
clip after clip after clip of me on my
show and with woman after woman after
woman showing she does not care what the
average man wants so knowing this
information it's really there's only
going to be changed when the top men
adapt to this sort of thing so you know
Andrew Tate comes in and actually it
looks like we're gonna get an Andrew
Tate and Dylan collab and he said if you
come to Romania we can Spar no problem G
Dylan says I have massive respect for
top G and his skill set it would be
awesome to get in some rounds with the
Cobra depending on his scheduling but
this is a huge possibility and you know
I would actually love to have a really
open conversation and I know this will
never happen because they'll probably
beat each other up but I I think it
would be good to have an open
conversation with the guys about body
count because you know
I'm pretty sure Dylan had an issue
dating promiscuous woman a promiscuous
woman I I'm sure Tate has at some point
like I don't think any man is immune to
having fallen in love with a hoe like I
think this is a pretty common Trope you
know beauty is powerful and as I've said
you know the women that men are
accepting as wives a hundred years ago
would have been thrown away it would
have been thrown out they would not have
been accepted so you know I've said this
before and I'll say it again most women
are very lucky to be alive in this time
period because a hundred years ago I
swear to God nobody would take us they'd
be like nope next next and so you know I
I just think we should have a general
conversation with the men that women
want to be with about what they actually
want because the issue we have is the
media is lying to us marketing is lying
to us and women we're so susceptible to
propaganda you know I can't think of one
girl in the media in the mainstream
media that has tradition no wife
qualities even the more like I guess
America's sweetheart kind ones seem to
have the same outcomes like I think of
Taylor Swift I think of Selena Gomez
they were really America's sweetheart
and yet they still are by themselves so
it tells us we we have a media and
marketing and really all the big
influencers don't want men and women to
be together and I think it goes back to
the egalitarian principle where men and
women we're told men and women are equal
and in my opinion we're just not